with a bullet to the face and a bunch of
traumatic memories rising to the surface
the first trailer for Sony's blood shot
is finally here and after what's felt
like an eternity of waiting the footage
surely should have been met with
thunderous applause and about a thousand
posts per minute on social media
Vin Diesel playing ray garrison a
murdered marine who comes back to life
and is infused with nanotechnology to
become the killing machine known as
bloodshot Academy award-winning
screenwriter Eric Heiser joining forces
with scribe Jeff Wadlow to pen the
script first-time feature film director
jeff wilson bringing the famous Valiant
Comics character to the big screen for
the first time ever sounds like a recipe
for comic book movie success that would
start with the release of the first
trailer but when Sony dropped the first
blood shot trailer on Monday October
21st many fans were left disappointed by
what they saw the biggest gripe some
fans have about the first bloodshot
trailer is that it doesn't feel like a
trailer at all it feels like an entire
film condensed into two minutes and 40
seconds
many people across Twitter and in the
comments section of the trailer on
YouTube expressed dissatisfaction over
the trailer seemingly spoiling all the
narrative beats of the film one user
tweeted whoever made this trailer should
be fired spoiled the entire movie in
just two minutes
another wondered why the trailer didn't
show off just a few action sequences
instead of apparently laying all its
cards out on the table
they wrote seriously why do they give
away the whole plot only a few action
sequences should be enough to build some
hype over on YouTube even more people
were upset over the evidently spoiler
heavy trailer one user wrote quote when
the movie comes out I'd say I watched it
already just from this trailer another
reason some fans were let down by the
brand new bloodshot trailer they feel
bloodshot doesn't look like bloodshot he
just looks like Vin Diesel one less than
impressed Twitter user wrote looks very
generic I would have prefered something
that embraced its comic origins more I
mean he doesn't look like bloodshot at
all it's just Vin Diesel and not
embracing the look of the comic they've
made it seem way more bland and generic
someone else tweeted quote I don't know
what ton about bloodshot but I'm fairly
sure he doesn't just look like regular
Vin Diesel one fan on reddit was
particularly displeased with the
character design or perhaps more at
currently lack thereof shown in the
first bloodshot trailer in a threat on
the movie subreddit they wrote I'm not
usually a stickler for this sort of
thing but the most core aspect of the
character design is that his body is
pure white he has a giant red dot on his
chest and his eyes are red and that was
completely abandoned for Peachy Vin
Diesel I guess it just feels like they
didn't even really want to try to make
this an adaptation of the comic maybe
I'm bitter I just wanted more from this
of course there's a strong chance that
the reason why bloodshot simply looks
like everyday Vin Diesel and this first
trailer is because his transformation
into the character fans know and love
from the valiant comics will happen
elsewhere in the film during his
sequence not shown in the trailer
since the footage did reveal quite a bit
about the plot of bloodshot perhaps the
film's team is holding off on revealing
bloodshot in all his glory until later
plus it's worth noting that the trailer
does feature a blink and you'll miss it
shot of a pale skinned red eye Diesel so
who knows thankfully for Sony executives
the bloodshot cast and creative team and
fans at home this is just the first
taste of the forthcoming flick as
bloodshot nears its February 21st 2020
release date there will likely be
several more trailers teasers TV spots
and promotional material rolled out to
boost anticipation if you weren't blown
away by this initial trailer perhaps a
future one will change your mind check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]